[Música]
i
buenas tardes cuando me invitaron y me
propusieron esto de decir ideas que
merecen ser compartidas la verdad que
hubo una palabra que me atrapó fue la
palabra revolución tiene mucho que ver
conmigo pero de esa palabra no vamos a
hablar ahora les voy a contar la palabra
que fue un cataclismo existencial no por
extraordinario super ordinario fue la
palabra no y la mejor manera de
compartir estas experiencias es dando
ejemplos vitales así que ahora les voy a
compartir algunos capítulos de mi vida
no ejemplar
hay a lo lejos y hace tiempo long long
time ago
había un adolescente que tenía clarísimo
que iba a hacer cuando saliera de la
secundaria iba a ser
esa decisión implicó todo un proceso de
discernimiento los retiros busquen
dirección espiritual y cuando estaba
terminando mi secundaria llegué con las
religiosas a las cuales yo me quería
unir las hermanas de la sagrada familia
y les comenté esto ellas me contestaron
que para poder sumarme y empezar ese
proceso tenía que tener por ser menor de
21 años la firma la autorización expresa
de mis padres
esto fue un problema porque hay un
capítulo que les tengo que contar
adicional y es que por aquella época con
mis papás no compartíamos la misma
mirada sobre lo que era la iglesia en
aquel momento decíamos no compartíamos
religión hoy sabemos que no tiene nada
que ver con eso pero cuando fui y le
dije a mis padres
quiero ser religiosa firmen el permiso
obtuve una respuesta tremenda
mis papás me dijeron
no
para mí eso fue tremendo desgarrador
ingeniero bronca impotencia una
frustración enorme
s no para mí fue tremendo y papá fue y
se juntó con las religiosas a las cuales
yo me quería unir y les expreso con
mayor claridad y contundencia
que ese no iba a ser firme hasta que
siguiera dependiendo de él es decir
hasta mi mayoría de edad imagínense lo
fue trágico fue uno que me cambió la
existencia uno que me abrazo
uno que casi me desgarro
y que hoy me doy cuenta me abrió un
montón de posibilidades
como tenía ese no patente y evidente no
me quedó otra que ir por un plan de
buscar alternativas
y cuando empecé a buscar alternativas
empecé a estudiar teología
soy profesora de teología y pastoral con
orientación laical
título los profetas para algunos que
todavía transitan en estas aulas
cuando estaba estudiando teología me
pasó algo único que no esperaba me
enamoré
viste cuando te enamoras las cosas pasan
acá
me enamoré y le encontré a ella
fue la verdad desconcertante
me enamoré de la filosofía
y cuando descubrí que la filosofía lo
que invitaba era curiosear a investigar
a preguntarse
esas tres pasiones nunca más dejaron mi
vida obviamente dado este capítulo que
les acabo de narrar con papá y con mamá
el problemita de la adolescente rebelde
que le dijeron que no la beca de hija se
me acabó cuando termina el secundario la
fader foundation no aportó más
eso significó que cuando salí del
secundaria mientras estudió teología
trabajé en estudio lo que muchos jóvenes
hacen no tiene nada de extraordinario lo
que sí pasó es que en el mundo del
trabajo me empezó a ir bien empecé a
crecer
empecé a tener oportunidades me gustaba
lo que hacía y con quienes lo hacía y en
un momento apareció el chance
tuve la oportunidad de un crecimiento y
en ese crecimiento
vino mi jefe de aquel momento y me dijo
no
con lo que sabes no te alcanza
s no me lo acuerdo perfecto porque fue
acá
o no sé cómo se grafica la pata del
hígado pero flaca
fue una frustración enorme una
impotencia una bronca
lo que más sufrió fue miedo claramente
cuando me apropie de ese no comprendí
hoy más que comprender me doy cuenta que
acepte que si me adueñaba de mi
ignorancia empezado a transitar el
camino de la posibilidad y fui por más
si no sabía lo suficiente tenía que
aprender tenía que estudiar y entonces
me sumergí en el mundo de los planes de
negocios de la rentabilidad de la macro
y microeconomía empecé a estudiar una
maestría en administración de empresas
base del mundo del ser y la nada al vil
metal
también eso generó una oportunidad y fue
de encontrar un match una integración
porque al fin y al cabo todo lo que
hacemos todo lo que decidimos es
nosotros
pude darme cuenta que somos uno entonces
seguí con ese estudio y llegó un momento
donde eso que estaba haciendo me había
mostrado o había aparecido por dos no
que me vinieron de la afuera el primero
me lo dieron mis papás desde el amor el
segundo me lo dio mi ex jefe desde el
desarrollo era momento de apropiarme de
mi existencia era momento de tener mi
propio no
como las buenas cosas suceden generan
mucho vértigo me di cuenta que no quería
tener más jefes ni horarios
no quería quien marcara lo que hacía ni
cuando lo hacía
y si no la verdad me molestó me inquieto
porque me invitaba a dar un salto un
paso al vacío a la incertidumbre yo
estaba cómoda haciendo lo que hacía
cuando abracé y me apropié de ese no
me entregué
y dio un paso a la incertidumbre
renuncie y empezó ahí el proyecto de
construir desde lo que ahora era nuevo
desde el mundo de la independencia
la verdad que ese apropiarme del mundo
de la independencia y no haberme quedado
instalada en el miedo de que no sabía lo
que iba a pasar fue muy grato creés y
aprendí me desarrolle me fui muy bien
hasta que obviamente volvió a pasar lo
inevitable
apareció un nuevo
no
y este no la verdad que me enojo me
molesto me frustro me acumulo todos los
no anteriores este no me decía ya sola
no
como ya solano si y aprendí una ley
matemática que a veces para sumar y
multiplicar tenemos que aprender a
dividir y restar
me di cuenta que él no sólo significaba
dividir honorarios dividir ingresos
compartirlos porque invitaba a un otro a
hacer nosotros y estaba construyendo un
equipo
gente con la cual vibramos en la misma
sintonía personas a las cuales admiro y
respeto profundamente
gente con la equivale y la pena
potenciarse
cuando me apropie de este segundo no
fuimos al infinito y más allá y la
verdad que cuando me invitaron a pararme
acá y contar de mí era una invitación a
salir de mi zona de confort a mí me
gusta ser cyrano y hacer que a otro le
dé la luz de frente y que brille
yo estoy mucho más cómoda cuando enseñó
a hablar que hablando de mis propias
experiencias pero encontré un sentido
para este sí y no decirle no a la
invitación y ese sentido fue honrar
agradecer
hacer un tributo
a ese primer grano
cuando quienes me dijeron que no están
acá sentados
lo hicieron los odie
pero tuve la posibilidad
de ir más allá de la palabra que a lo
mejor me hubiera destruido y me apropie
de la posibilidad
ahora me pregunto
cuál es el próximo no que me toca y
seguramente será uno que ponga yo
la luz de mi vida está por allí y
seguramente será la destinataria de este
no que yo vaya a poner lo cierto es que
si honro el no
se convierte en una posibilidad
si me apropió del límite
puedo avanzar
mi invitación hoy es enamorarse del no
que te esté frecuentando porque cuando
lo tomas de frente lo haces tuyo todo no
se convierte en un camino de
posibilidades
gracias por este no
y los invito a que busquemos de quien no
te podés apropiar que transforme tu
realidad como transformó la mía muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]